battlefield 2042 will not have a
campaign however that doesn't mean that
the game won't have a story as dice
revealed during a preview event in this
video we're gonna break down the exodus
short film that is released now and take
a look at how the narrative works this
game looks like it was crafted with the
fans in mind so i'm sure that there are
a bunch of easter eggs in the official
trailer do me a solid and use your eagle
eyes to spot what you can if you see
anything neat and toss them in the
comments i've been having a blast
thinking eating and dreaming about
battlefield 2042 and i'd love to do an
easter egg round up later for now though
let's talk story
the exit is trailer story is going to
hit real hard for those that enjoyed the
campaign in battlefield 4. a quick recap
for those out of the loop irish and
pakowski were both members of your squad
in battlefield 4 who survived a lot
together like being taken hostage by the
pla and trying to break free from a
sinking underwater vehicle in the
opening section of the campaign that's
an order
save yourselves get out of here
get out of here
man you hit me shoot out the window you
all die
buckowski kind of fit the mold of being
the younger brother of the team so to
speak and i'm sure there are battlefield
4 fans that were excited and interested
in seeing his return in the 2042 story
trailer some bad news on that front but
more on that later the real shocker
however is seeing irish and the reason
for this is simple at the end of
battlefield 4's campaign your character
wrecker makes the decision to send one
of two squad members on a ship to ensure
that a c4 detonates the understanding is
that whoever you send will perish and
you can choose to send irish as one of
the
on push options button
seeing irish in the new 2042 story
trailer implies that canonically he was
not sent down to the ship in battlefield
4 and that he lived to fight another day
both those characters are the focal
point of the exodus story trailer and
are now on opposite sides of a larger
brewing conflict between the us and
russia irish is a full on nopath he must
have left the united states and appears
to be working with another mysterious no
pat character named oz in irish's case
his motivations are crystal clear irish
has a son and he wants acceptance for
the no pats by these major nations and
is facing literal life or death
situations for his family that's all the
reason the man needs to take a stand for
his personal values rather than serving
a larger government without question
whereas irish wanted the notepads to be
seen and accepted by the major nations
oz wants something similar but through
radically different and more violent
means the notepads basically are shown
having ideological divides at times
despite having similar goals they fight
for the same people but their actions
and approaches are different oz's grand
plan seems to be to stay anonymous and
operate from the shadows and his
objective is to tear down the old order
for the no pats by triggering a massive
conflict he intends to uncover us
secrets that are bad enough to trigger
russia to engage in an all-out war the
actual name of the multiplayer mode the
idea is that if there's war then the
value of the no pat's rises which
coincides with oz's desire for a new
world where the nopats aren't at risk of
being forgotten and left to rot pak on
the other hand is still in allegiance
with the us trying to keep american
secrets and even calls out irish in the
story trailer calling him a traitor and
demanding to know why irish would become
a notepad irish
you traitor
oh
how much of the notepads pay you to [ __ ]
over your home country
my loyalty is with the refugees on this
boat
that includes you now
eventually though pack tragically
sacrifices his life for irish in the end
in a very heavy scene showing that their
personal bond was stronger than their
faction allegiance so that's all fine
and well for the high level conflict
going on in 2042 but what does that mean
for you the player it all circles around
nopats and the specialists that you take
control of every specialist has their
own personality and motivations tying
into the main story that looks like it
will play out over seasons the exodus
story trailer in this case sets up a
fight over a downed satellite on the
doha hourglass map we're not quite sure
if it'll be through community challenges
objectives in ltm or what specifically
for story purposes though the objectives
of the no pat soldier teams echo that of
irish and oz respectively those fighting
alongside irish are motivated by
preventing a larger war and keeping that
information secret and those fighting
alongside oz's ideology are there to
unveil the truth and trigger the war the
specialists will also have backstories
and won't be told exclusively through
cutscenes the story told so far can be
found on ea's website under the
battlefield section titled journey of
the nopats now this kind of storytelling
is incredibly par for the course of life
service style games destiny 2 apex
legends overwatch and even warzone are
all adopting this story style of letting
the world shape the foundation and drive
the plot forward however battlefield's
use of specialists has a direct
comparison to apex legends champion
backstories or modern warfare seasons by
having specialists have feelings towards
each other some good and some very bad
these specialist backstories will show
up and their interactions will occur
when it's their turn to basically drive
the story of the world forward now with
all of you caught up on how in-game
storytelling will potentially work in
battlefield 2042 let's circle back for a
minute and quickly talk about irish
irish is the nickname for kimball graves
and he's revealed to be another
specialist remember we've only learned a
select handful of the specialist
identities and dice has mentioned we
should be getting 10 at launch with more
throughout the seasons irish's role as a
specialist is in the engineer class and
his ability is creating a fortification
system irish can place defenses like a
dcs deployable cover which is a low
barricade with a see-through top you can
crouch behind it for cover and stand up
to return fire he also has an aps-36
shoot down sentinel which can shoot down
enemy explosive projectiles within
proximity like grenades or rockets all
specialists also have an intrinsic trait
and irish's trait is known as veteran
what this means is that irish can tank a
little bit with extra armor of his own
giving him another layer of defense the
small amount of body armor is equipped
when he spawns and can be replenished
whenever irish collects dropped ammo
packs from defeated foes we've now seen
so much from battlefield 2042 and
definitely dug our teeth into the
extremely hyped and recently announced
battlefield portal which means hazard
zone is all that's left we haven't heard
any word or details about battlefield
2042's non-battle royale mode just yet
but only that it is supposed to be shown
sometime before launch which should be
right around the corner there's a
current tech test actively going on
right now for those signed up for ea's
play testing and we also know that there
is an upcoming open beta in september so
if you are excited about battlefield
2042 and all the news coming in hot let
us know in the comments until next time
only one way to stop this war
that's to get in the middle of it
put a call out to any notepad who will
listen
36 hours
get ready
to fight
[Music]
[Music]
you